welcome to the movie theater of the
future if you thought 3d was cool try
adding moving chairs bubbles water just
strobe lights feet tickler and smoke
let's do it seat shaking I like the bus
moving exactly the company behind this
40 X technology is Korean theater chain
CJ it rolled out 40 X in its own
theaters first then chains in Europe and
Mexico came Kali
now AGL a live venue in downtown Los
Angeles is retrofitting one of its
theaters the process CJ says can cost
$700,000 to be competitive and relevant
in the movie business you have to
constantly be evolving and all this
movie theater magic can basically be
controlled through a tablet the effect
of digital is that you have this total
environmental control you're not just
you know shooting the movie out at the
same time but you have these effects
that are timed exactly with the movie
effects that engage four of the five
senses smells like gunpowder and freshly
brewed coffee or stored in canisters
behind the theater and piped in at the
right time smell some burning rubber
smells like burning rubber it's raining
let's bring in the theater and it's
raining
yeah the 4d experience costs around six
bucks more than 3d movie ticket an
upcharge exhibitors like AG hope will
pay off we anticipate that there will be
a strong demand to to roll it out into
other movie theaters but spider-man is
flying through the air you're moving
with him a little bit or so yeah you get
a sense of like floating a little bit
with boat whoa
then I can overcome